-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy Award-winning
comedian and actor
who is in his record-breaking
21st season on "SNL."
His memoir,
"When I Was Your Age:
Life Lessons, Funny Stories,
and Questionable
Parenting Advice
from a Professional Clown,"
is available now.
And "SNL" returns live on NBC
and Peacock this Saturday
with host Dakota Johnson
and musical guest
Justin Timberlake.
Please welcome back to the show,
one of the all-time greats,
Kenan Thompson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-My friend! My old friend.
-'Sup, everybody.
[ Applause ]
Hello, everyone.
Well, well, well.
Thank you.
-This is so exciting,
to see you here.
-What a nice reception.
-We've seen you here
for over two decades.
It is still exciting,
though, to...
-You're also right there.
-I know. I'm right here.
-"SNL" is, like, right there.
-We don't see
each other, though.
I mean, because again,
when you're right there,
you're doing your thing
When I'm here,
I'm doing my thing.
-Very true, very true.
But I also, that room
right down the hall,
where we both
auditioned for "SNL."
You talk about your audition
in this wonderful book.
It seems crazy
to even look back and think
there was a time
where "SNL" was weighing,
"Do we want Kenan Thompson?
Do we not want Kenan Thompson?"
But you said said,
one of the nice things is,
you could hear
certain laughs in your audition.
-Yeah.
-That was actually helpful
to be able to,
like, know ahead of time,
being a fan of the show,
like, how people laugh
so I could tell
who was laughing.
Lorne has a very kind of like,
master of the universe laugh.
-Yeah.
-Very low and guttural
when he really finds
something funny.
[ Imitates laugh ]
Alright. That's pretty good.
Tina, Tina Fey is, like,
a little more of a cackle.
It kind of explodes out of her.
-That's a very good way of
putting it.
-Because I guess she listens
to a lot of jokes
and stuff like that.
So when she finds
something actually funny --
[ Imitates laugh ]
All right, that's good.
Poehler is a good laugher.
She really --
She's like a kid laughing.
[ Imitates laugh ]
You know, that kind of thing.
-She's one of the best, one of
the most supportive laughers.
-Big time, loves the fact that
that was just funny, basically.
That's her thing.
Maya is like
a proud mom, you know?
[ Imitates laugh ]
It's like,
"Oh, Maya. That's nice.
She's a goddess."
And you have
a very funny laugh.
-You know, it's interesting.
I noticed in the book,
you said, "Google 'Muttley.'"
-Yeah.
-Which is a Hanna-Barbera.
I'm guessing?
-It is.
It's a reference
to the dog in Hanna-Barbera
that was very sneaky.
-And I will say,
I took your advice
and I said I was
going to Google it.
When I watched, I was like,
"Oh, son of a gun.
I do laugh like that."
-Yes, you do.
-Show the audience.
-Do we have it?
-This is how I laughed in our
years together at the table.
-It's only because
you're a little rascal.
Let's show it.
-[ Cackling ]
-That is.
That is kind of my laugh.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah.
-I did. It was so funny.
I was a little rascal.
-Yeah. It's like a little rascal
just found something funny.
[ Imitates laugh ]
-Yeah, I love it.
-Some of my favorite
things about this book
is not just your history
in comedy,
but also you talk about
your two wonderful daughters.
Very funny story about
going to your daughter Georgia
with help for a password.
-Yeah, I don't know
if you know this or not,
but children and technology
are really like this these days.
She is prolific and I am not.
And I went to her, asking her
for help for, like,
a log-in or something.
I was like, "Do I need to, like,
forget my password and get
an email and do all that?"
She was like, "Bruh,
let me just show you."
I was like,
"Did you just call me bruh?"
[ Laughs ]
Yeah, but that's what
happens with a 9-year-old
and you're getting on
their nerves.
-You did say there is
one thing that would be worse
than if your daughter
called you "bruh."
-Which is...
-"Kenan."
-Oh, yeah.
No, I can't do the first name
thing for children.
No. Show some respect.
-Yeah.
-It's "Dad."
-Can you imagine as a kid
calling -- even other parents,
who said, "Call me
by my first name."
-If I called my dad "Fletcher"?
Bro, I'd be across the room
in two seconds
with a foot to the face.
-You would be like,
"I had no idea
how fast you move, Fletcher."
-Yeah. Word.
"Good on you, Fletch."
Yeah, I love them.
They were just here.
We saw Justin Timberlake
do his music rehearsal just now.
-With your daughters?
Yeah, they came to check it out.
-And he took a picture.
He's the nicest.
-That's really exciting.
-It's really great.
-I mean, you now, finally,
your daughters are like,
kids get old enough
where you can actually now
be a gatekeeper
to things they find cool.
-Absolutely,
and it makes me cool.
-Yeah.
-It makes me feel good.
It makes me feel good
to be cool in my kids' eyes.
-Yeah.
My kids met Forte this summer.
You're kidding. How was that?
Of course,
kids love Will Forte, right?
-Come on. Who doesn't?
-And then they were on Hulu
messing around,
and they stumbled on
"Last Man on Earth,"
and they said, "What is this?"
And I said, "This is
a documentary about Will."
-Also at the end of the world.
It is a documentary.
-Will went through a bad time
before he met you.
-It was still one
of the greatest shows.
It's the greatest.
-Incredible.
-Shout out to Will Forte.
-Shout out to Will Forte,
making multi-generations laugh.
-Absolutely.
-21 years.
Hard to wrap your head around.
One of, of course, the most
iconic things on the show,
which you've been lucky enough
to do a lot of times,
is scream "Live from New York."
I would imagine
that never gets old.
I did it a handful of times
and it was always exciting.
-It doesn't get old,
and it also doesn't have a fame
level to where it's not cool.
I've seen like, Obama do it
and just really be tickled
by the fact that he's doing it.
You know what I mean?
And anybody else that has,
you know, uber-uber-fame,
you know,
McCartney's done it,
Mick Jagger's hosted.
All these people
that have had the opportunity
to say that line.
There's just something
about it, it's so historic.
It's so beloved
and you know that.
And you're also presenting,
you know,
a good time to the country.
-And everybody's cheering
after you say it.
-Yeah, yeah.
It's never like, you drop it.
It doesn't hit
the ground at all.
No, "Live from New York,"
it's like, "Yeah!"
It's never like,
"Live from New York."
-"This is Meet the Press!"
Nobody would yell.
-No, just....
-And that's been on
for a long time, too,
but nobody gives a [bleep].
-No.
Nobody gives a --
-Don't tell Fletcher I cursed.
-I won't.
-I have a lot more
questions for you.
We'll be right back
with more Kenan after this.